[Musique]
non
on
je compatis
m
le plus rapidement possible
[Musique]
la situation a atteint des proportions
effectivement extrêmement grave avec de
nombreux actes de violence qui ont été
constatées et usage d'armes à feu et de
force létale est extrêmement inquiétant
on rappelle quand même que les forces de
l'autre conformément au droit national
et international ne doivent utiliser la
force létale que dans des circonstances
exceptionnelles et en aucun cas dans des
opérations de maintien de l'ordre
nous avons pu observer à différents
endroits de la capitale
des hommes en tenue civile armés de
gourdins et à bord de deux pick up qui
est donc été aperçue aux côtés des
forces de sécurité et qui ont frappés
pourchassés frappé des manifestants
devant les forces de sécurité ce que
nous disons c'est que les ban doit
absolument à permettre la présence
d'individus non identifiés comme faisant
partie des forces de l'ordre pour des
opérations de maintien de la paix et
donc il faut que la lumière soit faite
sur le rôle exact et la fonction de ces
personnes
le fait de s'attaquer aussi à des ad des
lieux qui sont considérés comme
présentant un intérêt sans scène magasin
auchan et eiffage ou où les jets station
essence total c'est aussi un signal que
manifestement certains souhaitent
envoyer ou aux autorités françaises en
leur demandant de ne pas de ne pas
soutenir vous prendre parti pour
quelqu'un qui peut-être aurait faussé le
jeu politique
[Musique]
à
jarome iginla
raoult de justice de la cedeao il ya
quelques mois sur un cas concernant le
togo avait clairement indiqué que
restreindre et l'internet est une
atteinte aux droits et perpétration 2 et
d'informer c'est un moyen de censurer
l'information d'empêcher les gens de
communiquer et de et de filtrer ce que
les autorités voudraient vouloir voir
[Musique]
il ya un contexte social et pour nous
que politique est très très difficile et
probablement un peu la goutte qui fait
déborder le vase c'est à dire que les
gens sont fatigués les gens ont beaucoup
de mal à tenir les à joindre les deux
bouts
un couvre-feu qui est très mal vécue
régulièrement au sénégal et une
impression que la liberté des citoyens à
choisir l'eau aux dirigeants de leur
choix qui ne semble leur échapper aussi
un sentiment profond d'une grande
instrumentalisation de la justice à des
fins politiques
avec l'élimination progressive d'un
certain nombre de figures politiques
voir le sénégal rejoindre le camp des
pays qui répriment des libertés qui
pourrait plonger dans la stabilité
évidemment est extrêmement inquiétant
est préoccupant pour nous
[Musique]